-With COVID cases
once again on the rise,
especially in places where
vaccination rates have lagged,
the GOP and Fox News
have been freaking out
about President Biden's plan
to conduct community outreach
to raise awareness
about the vaccines.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Yesterday was a big day
at the White House.
Pop star Olivia Rodrigo
met with President Biden
and Dr. Anthony Fauci
to promote COVID vaccines
among young people.
And in addition to providing
a much-needed boost
to efforts to get
more people vaccinated,
it also gave us
the gift of Fauci,
one of our most beloved
and celebrated scientists,
explaining to the best
of his ability who Rodrigo is.
-You're going to meet with
singer Olivia Rodrigo tomorrow
at the White House.
What do you think
that she can do
to try to persuade younger
people to get vaccinated?
-Well, I understand that
she's a very popular figure
among young individuals.
-That sounds like one of those
weird next generation episodes
where Data is explaining
to Riker who Elvis Presley was.
"He was an influential musician
of the mid-20th century.
Apparently,
he died on a toilet."
Of course, you can't blame Fauci
for not always keeping up
with the times.
He's an 80-year-old
immunologist.
Fauci's idea of a pop star
is probably Eddie Cantor.
"We need to reach out
to young people.
Any ideas, Dr. Fauci?"
"What about Bobby Goldsboro?
Mel Tormé?
Oh, and can we get Perry Como?"
Fauci doesn't know anything
about modern music,
nor should he.
He probably knows
Leonard Bernstein
and that's it,
which is fitting since,
when he goes back
to his old neighborhood,
he probably acts
like a character from
"West Side Story."
"Hey, it's Tony the Fauch!
Looking good, Fauch!"
"Right back at ya, Mickey."
"Tony, watch out.
The Republicans
are looking for you."
"Hey, don't worry, Artie.
The Fauch ain't no slouch."
♪ Fauci, Fauci ♪
♪ Crazy Fauci ♪
Anyway...
[ Laughter ]
This was a genuinely great
and admirable thing
that Rodrigo did.
We desperately need
as many trusted sources
across a wide swath
of society
to raise awareness
about the vaccines
and push back against
all the toxic misinformation
pushed by the right.
And if you watched
her comments yesterday,
I think you'd agree
that Rodrigo was very effective
at getting the message out.
-I am beyond honored
and humbled to be here today
to help spread the message
about the importance
of youth vaccination.
I'm in awe of the work
President Biden and
Dr. Fauci have done
and was happy to help
lend my support
to this important
initiative.
It's important
to have conversations
with friends
and family members
encouraging all communities
to get vaccinated
and actually get
to a vaccination site,
which you can do more easily
than ever before,
given how many sites we have
and how easy it is to find them
at vaccines.gov.
Side note here -- It's nice
to see a real celebrity
at the White House
after the last four years,
when the previous President
could only manage
to dig up the likes
of Ted Nugent or Scott Baio.
Biden's got huge celebrities
helping him out
with an unprecedented
nation-wide campaign
to get Americans vaccinated
against the deadly disease.
And all Trump could muster
was 18 holes with Kid Rock
in his flag pants,
which looks like something
you'd buy for 6 bucks
at a truck stop
because you tore the ass
out of your good pants
rock climbing on peyote.
You might be asking yourself,
"They sell pants
at truck stops?"
Uh, yeah.
You think truckers
go cross-country
wearing one pair of pants
the whole time?
Get real.
That is, unless they buy
my new product, Perma-Pants.
And if you're wondering
how I'm gonna sell them,
I'm going to grow a mustache
and start talking like this.
"The best thing
about Perma-Pants
is you can go on the go,
and you don't have to pull over
and pee in the woods
and risk getting eaten
by da bears."
I made so much money
from Perma-Pants,
I was able to buy a diamond ring
from Da Bears.
I also bought some earrings
for my wife, Deborah.
And then the salesman asked
what they were for,
and I said, 'Deb's ears.'"
You see...
what happened here
is Shoemaker
texted us last night
and said, "FYI, plenty of time
for tomorrow's 'Closer Look.'"
And we said,
"Challenge accepted."
I mean, Shoemaker,
why would you do that?
That's like texting
a recovering alcoholic,
"No line at the bar."
The whole reason
I went to impression camp
was so I could stop
doing impressions.
And you come along
like a drug dealer saying,
"Psst, hey, kid,
want to do a Lindell?
How about a Tony the Fauch?"
By the way, Shoemaker
also went to tangent camp.
And if you want to know
how to get there,
you take a hard left, and then
you just keep [bleep] going.
Now, part of the reason
the appearance from Rodrigo
was necessary and valuable
was that it will hopefully
help push back
against vaccine misinformation
being pushed
by the GOP
and right-wing media.
For example, they've recently
started claiming
that Joe Biden's plan to conduct
targeted community outreach
and go door-to-door to raise
awareness about vaccines
is actually a sinister
government effort
to take your guns
and your Bibles
and force you to take
whatever medication
the government
wants you to take.
-And now they're starting
to talk about going door-to-door
to be able to take vaccines
to the people.
Think about the mechanisms
they would have to build
to be able to actually execute
that massive of a thing,
and then think about
what those mechanisms
could be used for.
They could then go door-to-door,
take your guns, again go door
to door, take your Bibles."
-Don't come knocking on my door
with your Fauci ouchie.
You leave us the hell alone.
-Going door-to-door?
This is creepy stuff.
You know, if someone
comes up to your door
outside wearing a mask,
showing up at your house,
claiming to work
for the government,
asking you personal
medical questions?
-Can HHS force you to take
antibiotics for your TB?
How about Xanax
for your anxiety?
Thorazine for your mania?
And while we're at it, why
are we letting irresponsible,
defective people reproduce --
vagrants, mental patients,
even QAnon people?
All are allowed
to have children.
Why is that?
Why aren't we sterilizing them?
Sound crazy?
-What else
can the government do?
Can they force you
to take aspirin
when you have a headache?
Can they strap you down
and slather you in Bengay
if your back hurts?
Can they have mall security
drag you out of Brookstone
for spending too much time
in the massage chair,
even though you show them
a doctor's note
that says you have
an enlarged tailbone
and you have
a constitutional right
to sit in the electric massage
chair for as long as you want?
And then they say,
"That's not a doctor's note.
It's written on a Post-it,"
and everyone
in the store laughs,
and you say, "Oh, I'm sorry.
I guess because my doctor
works out of a Staples,
I'm not
an American citizen anymore."
And while everyone's
busy laughing,
you try to fish some quarters
out of the mall fountain,
and they say,
"You can't do that.
And you say, "Well, how else
am I supposed to buy
a box of garlic knots
from Sbarro?"
And they say, "There's
no Sbarro at this mall.
It was replaced by
B. Dalton Booksellers."
And you say, "Well,
welcome to Joe Biden's America."
And as you're saying it,
you fall ass first
into the fountain
and nearly drown
until the mall cop
revives you by doing CPR
without getting
your permission first.
Does that sound crazy to you?
Also, can we go back to this?
-Going door-to-door?
This is creepy stuff.
You know, if someone
comes up to your door
outside wearing a mask,
showing up at your house,
claiming to work
for the government,
asking you personal
medical questions?
-Well, you can make
anything sound creepy
when you say it like that.
Someone comes up to your door
wearing high socks,
short shorts, and a bucket hat,
opens your mailbox,
takes all the outgoing mail,
puts it in a van
that looks suspiciously like
an ice cream truck,
and drives it away,
I know you're not
the ice cream man.
You're not fooling me,
government.
In reality,
it is a volunteer effort.
And all they're doing
is trying to raise awareness
about life-saving vaccines
amid a deadly pandemic.
And look, I get that
if you still
don't have the vaccine
and you watch Fox News,
you are not
going to be convinced
by someone
knocking on your door.
But it's still nice
that they're trying.
It's not like they're working
on commission
or trying to get you
to upgrade to
Pfizer's
Pfriends & Pfamily Plan.
Everyone just wants
this pandemic to end.
And the fastest way out
is the vaccine.
COVID cases in the U.S.
have doubled in recent weeks,
and CBS reported a few days ago
that almost all of
the new cases, 99.7% percent,
are among people
who have not been vaccinated.
It's tragic,
and it's unnecessary.
We have an abundance
of safe, effective,
and free vaccines
for anyone who wants one.
And yet, the right
has even gone so far
as to insist that Democrats
or the media
or anyone who wants to combat
the spread
of this deadly disease
is somehow addicted
to the pandemic.
-They just can't let
the pandemic go.
At some point, it's --
they're going to have to
break the addiction.
-Well, and it's like
some of these people
get put out there all the time
when they have been dead wrong
over the last year.
-Hmm. And then when you say,
"Some of these people
have been dead wrong,"
are you referring to the guy
who said a deadly plant toxin
could cure coronavirus
or the guy who said last year
that COVID deaths
are almost nothing
or the guy who said we could
cure coronavirus
by eating Tide To Go sticks
like French fries
and complimented a doctor
who believes in demon sperm?
Remember that? I mean, how
could you forget demon sperm?
Sounds like the name
of a monster truck
or a knockoff energy drink you'd
find at the counter at a bodega.
Also, do you think
we can't quit the pandemic?
Are you insane?
I'm so sick of this pandemic.
When it's over,
I'm going to celebrate by going
to a giant indoor concert
where we all burn our masks,
drink ayahuasca
out of a shared cup,
and make out with each other.
We all want this God-forsaken
nightmare to be over with,
which is why we're trying
to convince people
to get vaccinated,
but maddeningly,
we're dealing with
a political movement
that's made spreading lies
about vaccines
one of their central
political projects.
It's become a culture-war issue
for them.
They're even selling merch now.
-Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
introduced new coronavirus-
themed campaign merchandise.
These are some of the items
being sold
on the governor's official
campaign website.
There's a drink koozie with
a quote from DeSantis asking,
"How am I going to drink a beer
with a mask on?"
And a T-shirt that reads,
"Don't Fauci my Florida."
-Cool.
So the Republican Party
is basically
just Hot Topic for boomers now.
Florida is currently
reporting daily cases
close to four times
the national average,
with the second-highest number
in the country.
And DeSantis is selling merch
like he's at a folding table
outside Warped Tour.
Can't wait for DeSantis
to show up to his next interview
in a new t-shirt
with a studded belt,
a pierced nose,
and jet-black hair.
And what does that even mean?
"Don't Fauci my Florida"?
Is that supposed to be
a play on words?
It sounds like a mad lib filled
out in a concussion ward.
Also, poor Fauci. He's an
80-year-old New York doctor.
The natural next step for him
was to move to Florida.
Now he can't.
Old New Yorkers move to Florida
the way sea turtles migrate.
It's just instinct.
One day they're at the top
of the subway stairs
with a bag from Zabar's,
and something in them
goes, "'F' it."
Next thing they know,
they're in Boca
putting a basket of seashells
on the back of a toilet.
"I'm home."
Every sane person
wants the pandemic to end
as quickly as possible,
and the best way to do that
is to get as many people
vaccinated as we can.
We have an abundance of safe,
effective, and free vaccines
available
for anyone who wants one.
We just need to keep
getting the word out.
Instead,
large parts of the right
are spreading dangerous
lies about the vaccines.
The sane political movement
in this situation
would be doing the opposite.
They'd be telling
the government, "Please"...
-Come knocking on my door
with your Fauci ouchie.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over two million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses,
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the "donate" button.
Stay safe, get vaccinated.
We love you.